Es ist soweit morgen früh wird der länder mascotte auf dem asteroiden rio galanten es ist der höhepunkt einer
spektakulären mission rom gehört zur klasse der erdbahn kreuzen asteroiden und könnte der erde
potenziell gefährlich werden die mission will mehr über diese asturien erfahren und daten sammeln
um ein schläger auf der erde in zukunft zu verhindern klicks und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich neue science videos abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich willkommen
Zuerst mal der hinweis auf unseren live stream zur raumfahrt heute
abend um 20 uhr hier bei pixum von diesem sofa der link ist in der video beschreibung und unter dem hier
oben es geht um solche missionen flüge zum mars mond und so weiter wenn er fragen dazu habt schreibt sie gerne hier in die kommentare
für mitgliedern pattons geht es übrigens schon um 1930 los ihr bekommt die infos per whatsapp und ihr
unter dem community tag zum thema schon 2014 war die raumsonde hayabusa hat zwei gestartet ende juni
2018 hat sie sie dann ihr ziel fast erreicht den asteroiden rio die japanische raumfahrtagentur jaxa
meldete dass die sonder sich nun 20 kilometer von rio befinde und von dort aus messungen vornehmen werde
das ganze spielt sich rund 300 millionen kilometer von uns entfernt ab aber hugo ist nicht immer so weit weg manchmal ist er auch näher
er befindet sich auf einer umlaufbahn um die sonne die die erdumlaufbahn
kreuz damit gehört er zu den potentiell gefährlichen asteroiden
die auf der erde einschlagen können und diese mission hat das ziel mehr über diese asteroiden klasse zu erfahren hayabusa 2
wird in den nächsten anderthalb jahren den asteroiden vermessen
2020 soll die sonde dann zur erde
zurückkehren und proben mitbringen die bei einem dichten überflug eingesaugt werden dafür wird sie mitte nächsten jahres einen inspektor auf den asteroiden
schießen und beim überflug das aus dem entstandenen krater
ausgeworfene material aufsaugen zudem hat sie bereits zwei länder abgesetzt die bereits
spektakuläre bilder von der oberfläche gemacht haben mit an bord der deutsche mini roboter namens
mascotte entwickelt vom dlr der aus einer höhe von 100 metern auf den asteroiden absinken soll
16 stunden batterielaufzeit bleiben dem länder um daten zu erheben
dabei nimmt die kamera mesz camp bereits während des abstiegs bilder auf nach der landung wird sie die umgebung der
landesstelle bis zum horizont in hoher auflösung fotografieren und führt auf der asteroiden oberfläche
biologische und physikalische
messung der umgebung und des untergrunds durch das radio meter misst die
oberflächentemperatur sowie die thermischen eigenschaften des oberflächen materials das infrarotspektrum
mikroskop mikrometer ein instrument des institut d'astrophysique
spaziale paris ups richtig ausgesprochen ermittelt die
mineralogische zusammensetzung der oberfläche das magnetometer mag eine entwicklung des instituts für geophysik und extraterrestrische physik
der technischen universität braunschweig wird das magnetfeld des asteroiden vermessen ein heftiges programm
das macht mascotte an verschiedenen orten dabei bewegt sich der bot mit einem schwung am von ort zu ort
die gravitation des asteroiden ist nämlich so schwach dass bei jeder anderen
fortbewegung die gefahr bestünde vom asteroiden wegzufliegen überwacht wird das zehn kilogramm schwere gerät von köln aus vom
dlr dem deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt dort gibt es auch einen live stream auf denen wir in der video beschreibung verlinken
für die wissenschaft wird diese mission wichtige daten erheben neben den
informationen über möglicherweise auf der erde einschlagen der asteroiden werden wir auch mehr zu den ursprüngen des sonnensystems erfahren hast du ihnen wie ringo
sind überreste aus der frühzeit unseres sonnensystems
heute abend also unser raumfahrt
livestream hier vom sofa schreibt gerne eure fragen in die kommentare oder auch whatsapp mit dem hashtag livestream
unter diesem link hier könnt ihr euch den live stream um 20 uhr schon mal vormerken
für pence und mitglieder geht es bereits um 1930 los den link zu diesem hang out werden wir euch
also den mitgliedern im community tab den patriots auch whatsapp und direkt auf bett
schicken nochmal ab 20 uhr wird das team für die gesamte clixoom community
öffentlich gemacht und wir diskutieren zusammen und fachsimpeln zusammen und wenn er nie was wir verpassen wollt dann da abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran